we've got to quickly mention uh the show
everyone's obsessed by The Last of Us
Pedro and Britain's own Bella Ramsay
there yeah yeah I had no idea she was
British really no well you saw Game of
Thrones didn't you no oh you didn't oh
what it's got dragons in it why would I
watch that
I'm a friend and then I mean I've seen
all your episodes
I don't think I've ever read such good
reviews for a television show I mean
they're incredible rap for us were you
familiar with the game I didn't know
about the game before I got the job and
then I got the job and I found out very
quickly about the game it's a very
famous video game yeah I've heard that
um
you haven't played The Last of Us no
I needed it needed to be explained to me
um but when I when I when I got the job
I I uh I was very familiar with HBO I
was very familiar with Craig Mason who
who created uh Chernobyl yeah and uh but
I called my sister who's got two teenage
boys uh uh and I was on speakers when
she answered she was dropping them off
at school and she's like what's going on
and I said well there's this job offer
and uh uh or opportunity
um that uh it's based actually on a
video game and uh Bruno and better are
my nephew's names and they're like what
is it I was like it's called the LA The
Last of Us
you better get that job
you talk about getting that job your
experience of getting that job quite
hazy I think yeah I was in London I was
in London
okay okay so it all happened very very
quickly it was a very strange thing
where it was read the scripts talk to
Craig uh uh us and then you know it was
getting later and later at night and uh
was shooting in London at the time and
uh
they needed me to stay up late to meet
the creator of the video game and the
executive producer Carolyn Strauss who
was on Game of Thrones and um to
continue kind of like you know
convincing trying to convince them to
hire me for the job and um by the time
it was all said and done it was late and
uh I uh
I took a an Ambien a sleeping sleeping
tablet that's that's strong to go to bed
yeah because I knew that I needed to
because I was at that point I was kind
of hyped up yeah the next day but yeah
and I was excited about the the prospect
so they called me and to tell me that I
had gotten the job but I had already
taken the tablet
because I really didn't think I thought
that I would at least have to wait until
the next day you know and um okay yeah I
remember actually that's cool yeah yeah
I was like oh my God and then like a
couple of minutes on the call went by
apparently and I was like so what's up
did you did I get the job
what what are you talking about we
called you we told you you got the job
and I was like oh I did
what's it and I was like oh I took a
tablet I
forgot that completely woke up in the
morning it was all like oh my god did I
get the job
day there in L.A I'm in London
waiting by the phone and everything and
and and I I had gotten the job I'm
surprised you kept the job
Pedro Pascal continues his run of great
TV hits with season three of the
Mandalorian can you tell us anything
about season three yes I'll tell you
everything
when you're doing the scenes do you know
that at all times you're being upstaged
Bye absolutely
let them do all the heavy lifting and
baby Yoda like a lot of these things are
green screen but baby Yoda is there yes
baby it is there and what is there's two
different versions of I can't believe I
believe I see the Yoda well you're not
supposed to say that that's the first
time
oh
I gotta go
they're waiting for you it's broken
yeah but he's baby Yoda right um you
know just just following the rules okay
Zoe's baby grogu and uh but it's a
what's there
[Laughter]
thank you
[Applause]
what was the question uh what's that
what's there so there's two there's two
yeah one that goes by remote okay
um and it it is the most immaculately
made realistic looking creature
um by remote so that you can work in a
wide shot and his ears will move and
he'll look up at you and stuff like that
and steal the scene yeah yeah and um and
then there's one for the close-ups and
stuff where it's he's like wired into
Nassau NASA you know what I mean
Nassau County everyone
but he is it's so like the eyebrows and
the eyeballs and the teeth and the
little fingernails and everything and
he's all
um fully fully there and they're like a
real seeing partner to be honest does he
have a mess with you they mess they they
can make them do whatever you know and
they're there yeah
and I was like oh you know
um you're really really chewing up the
scene on this one aren't you and he's
like yeah
looks up at me and when adults recognize
you as the Mandalorian in the street in
life right they want you to do the voice
yeah to their well because they get so
excited and they say my kid loves the
Mandalorian and then you know they'll
either it'll be a FaceTime thing or
they'll be like hey you know Charlie
this is the Mandalorian and they're like
what what and they look at me
and they're like who the hell is that
and then they're like well you know do
the you know do the voice
well no I I I I tried to once but it
sounded so inappropriate because it's
actually kind of a very breathy low
register
bedroom voice
you know
it's like yeah it's me you know it's
like it's like it's just like so creepy
close your eyes and listen to my voice
no it doesn't work
but you are your family are huge fans
Pedro and there's a lot of them there's
so many yeah like there's dozens of 34
first cousins
really yeah so they must be all very
excited that you're now this big star oh
gosh yeah
they're like you little
you were so annoying
you finally got all the attention you
were after but don't they they call you
and ask for favors and things they do
yeah
yeah like yeah they all have my phone
number
they have my phone number and they they
give it out
oh I get messages every day every day
every day every day would you say this
for my birthday or my school my
daughter's graduating or my you know
nurse is you know having a baby or my
priest is upset and you know like like
you always have to do the voice
they will let me be myself I think for
the most part but I think that there
there are no limits for what what what
may be requested you fail to learn a
skill on the kingsman didn't you Pedro
uh the last who yeah I even said it the
way it said here because it's a lasso
lasso it's totally Alaska like Alaska
in America you say absolutely I've never
heard that yeah
I feel we're being pranked
laughs I've never heard I've never heard
that and it was and you know I've worked
with Harrison Ford in 1923
[Applause]
did you try to learn to whatever I was
terrible with the lasso I was good with
the whip oh there you are you were that
was the electric lasso but uh there's
nothing there
and so it was really just kind of a rope
that ended here and you know you had the
green tape and the rest was uh special
effects but you had to
um you know make it convincing and sort
of shake with it and you want me to I I
should do it right oh yeah yeah oh nice
[Applause]
I saw it
definitely giving Daddy
I mean because you know because like I
say you've been in the business for a
long time are you enjoying all this
sudden attention yeah
Ariana back to your Oscar
like for instance what are you are you
the daddy of the internet what's
internet Daddy
me yeah you are
uh internet Daddy yeah I'm still trying
to figure it out no people are like this
daddy there's daddy
um
okay with a z i mean that sounds that's
very like silver foxy it's like kind of
an air about you like it is I'll take it
off I guess
that's the thing is
Daddy no there's memes and stuff but
even on Twitter they're all going crazy
for it uh like I I need to stop calling
Pedro Pascal Daddy it's becoming a
problem uh yeah we're pretty much have
to scream daddy every time I see Pedro
Pascal on my screen
is my cool Daddy
yes and then I love this one down here
Pedro Pascal is a biblically gorgeous
man I want to feed him grapes I want to
Fan him with the front of a date palm
Forest lemon I want to find the
alabaster vial of perfume oil that one
woman broke for Jesus and comb it
through his hair
yeah I'm gonna DM that person
and the last sentence is like he's
stressing me out
and actually talking of the internet and
and religion Ariana Dubose on Facebook
under religion on your profile what does
it say uh well it used to say Helen
Mirren
welcome to that church and you could all
worship at the altar of Dame Helen in
her new movie Shazam Fury of the Gods
and so the three sisters your goddesses
yeah what gives what's happening yeah oh
gosh don't ask me
[Laughter]
but anyway our powers have been taken
from us and we're very cross and Shazam
took them from us and we've come back
and we've come down to earth to take
them back but of course they are young
kids playing and I'm sure you know this
from your your experience with
Mandalorian they live in another world
they talk a language I do not understand
you know I would I'd be sitting amongst
them and I got embarrassed to say too
many times I'm sorry what are you
talking about what are you referencing
all the references are I mean I don't
know half the references that kids are
saying today I'm still again there's one
that I learned recently that's really
wonderful and somebody was saying you
swerve do you know what swerving is no
no swerving yes I was like I was like oh
take get somebody off your scent or
something like that I don't know confuse
somebody and and they were like no you
they come in for a kiss and you swerve
great yeah
only if you don't want the kids
will you kiss me no I will all right I
just know that I would never swerve on
you
okay so you've chose spot swerving
oh Petra it's so lovely to see you how
are you doing
um
[Applause]
you can't be swerved
[Music]